that's actually what I'm up here doing
I'm talking to probably 20 or 30 highly
respected people about ways to get this
to connect I've thrown a lot of
resources into the Northeast because the
idea here just pick a grain wheat people
say okay we well you can't just do wheat
but let's just say you did new the
Northeast is negative their import
essentially all of their week if you're
thinking about landrace systems we were
net exporting which may or may not have
been good because the idea of food as a
weapon was invented in the Northeast and
then applied worldwide so we have some
recognition for that the idea of
producing cheap food started up here
that doesn't mean it's bad up here but
the idea of cheap food that we could
export and cut undercut prices worldwide
the first floors in the London exchange
that were not set on the London exchange
were set out of the northeastern United
States and then the immediately no
kidding went to the west coast and for
the next century for 1800 forward for
the first 50 years of evolution 1775
1825 all the floors for grain for export
and the London exchange were set in the
Northeast after 1825 to 1900 that
developed and shifted from the Northeast
to California and we set all the wheat
floor prices for international commodity
work off the London exchange out of
California what I find fascinating about
that is that in doing the floor setting
in the Northeast we lost the connection
to the vital part of our north eastern
cuisine that had identity and
place-based meaning and so I'm up here
now tilting at that windmill it's
quixotic what is the connection between
all the farming systems
before we had to produce an export up
here Native American so I'm working with
people in the Diaspora because we don't
really have a super viable native
farming system in the Northeast but all
of our best sake corn is still Native
American Abenaki Native American corn is
indigenous domain in the northeastern
corridor up there what's known as
northeastern Flint Algonquin Iroquois
and now an Ida and it had to go to
Canada before we worried about losing it
and so now the best seedsman for to
scott hill and he's in the middle of
nowhere in canada at six nations they're
just keeping that seat available so when
we look at those foods and how first
settlement interacted with native
american foods like happened where i'm
from we don't get a blazing meaning we
get Boston baked beans we get lots of
aberrations of the Diaspora from the old
world much stronger showing through into
modern times then we do in the south
because we had to take a holiday after
the Civil War all the resources were
wiped out so nothing changed for a long
time that poverty in the South kept a
lot of these systems in gear and intact
a lot longer than happened in the
Northeast so there's a lot more work to
do up here and when I bring it up with
the best chefs up here and I've brought
it up with all of them they look kind of
as well we're growing all these heirloom
foods where's the cuisine are you if
you're doing some of the best squash
that's most indigenous up here where's
the cuisine with that I said on the bio
diversity committee for slow food USA
and what is being done individually is
extraordinary there are teams right this
minute scouring the woods all over New
England looking for lost apples right
now they go out every day every day 365
days a year that's pretty extraordinary
they're looking for
genetics to keep the diversity and when
then I say okay so how do you knit the
cuisine of this massive diversity of
apples past say what Michael Pollan
wrote about in the documentation for
what Johnny Appleseed's known for which
is Applejack what would where is the
diversity past there that knits into a
full cuisine not just into Apple cuisine
because there is one up here and it's
phenomenal just like there's a maple
cuisine up here that's tied to Native
Americans directly the term see which if
you're doing your own sugar in you get
right at the end with the peak of the
SAP production you take that best stuff
and that's the first stuff you reduce
and you reduce it all the way down to
near scorch point and then you take a
stick and you roll up a ball and its
that thick and then you can lay it out
really quick in a ribbon on the snow
because you're still doing it because
the definition of sugaring is when the
snow is gone at the trunk of the tree
sugars over SAP tastes like crap anyhow
so you lay this really super
concentrated maple syrup down on the
snow roll it back up and you got a maple
snow cone that's the best thing you ever
had in your life and at sea and I want
to know how that relates to a cuisine
not the fact that it's extraordinary
that people still do it but how does it
relate to a cuisine where does that fit
in to the larger thing because if we
take sorghum in the south which is our
maple syrup and we actually track its
existence we know that sorghum was
different on every plantation and
sorghum when reduced properly had the
identity of the plantation or its place
based identity in its flavor profile and
the way it was judged was that the stage
stops so if you're in Charleston South
Carolina during say the 1700s and you're
going by stage to Savannah well you
could tell which state stop you were at
by the way they'd stir sorghum into
water the way it tasted you could taste
the difference that people would get on
the stage because it was a rotten ride a
lot of time to get on the stage dead
drunk in Charleston and
to somewhere they know where they were
by taste in the water this was something
maybe you don't want to promote that
sort of lifestyle but I want to know
where the connection for that sort of
thing is in New England I'm sure it's
here but I don't hear about it i'm
fascinated with that you know for the
same reason i'm fascinated with it in
the South fascinated with it up here too